hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the let's play the
Slenderman shadow maps today we're gonna
play the Christmas special so let's not
beat around the bush
alright so it's either a little bit late
for Christmas or a lot early so I'm
gonna give them the benefit of the doubt
I pretty much expected something like
that collect all eight presents so I'm
gonna give him the benefit of the doubt
and say that he's just a little bit late
ooh nice music not really Christmasy
just yet
but I mean it's nice oh I love the blood
flowing out of the machines that really
adds a holiday festive touch to it
oh there we go
that's Christmassy owner of Slendy 'he's
gonna have like a Santa hat when he pops
out that is assuming it's still Slendy
that's after me I'm not demon Santa
that's how he gets around the world in
no time he teleports is that a wall over
oh hello Boop
haha sorry Santa I'm sorry maybe maybe
we can like guess that this is us
infiltrating santa's workshop and he's
none too happy about that fact and he
wants to get us so that we don't spoil
next christmas because he's not ready
he's only made a few yeah that's it
I'm even I think I'm I think I'm going
out of the realm of the map here
ah another present yay it's just a fun
happy magical time what's over there
what is this what is this thing where
did I go did I just loop in a circle
what
what's with it I don't think I don't
think Santa had anything like that in
his workshop whatever this is the giant
ass tile I heard this down okay
oh no you don't ah not today slender you
can't go through that all right what
have you gotten this present anything
see a present at least the presents are
easier aha at least these are easier to
spot then like anything that I've seen
before at least these kind of stand out
what snowman
Slendy no snowman is he okay good plenty
now snowman I don't know what to expect
no I mean I actually do know what to
expect it's either Slendy with a Santa
hat or it's Santa Santa Slendy Slendy ah
ah ha ha oh holy hell go away I SATA and
a Santa ha ha ha ha my sorry Santa
I'm not trying to ruin Christmas holy
crap
ha ha oh very good boy hey loving a good
boy ha ha he doesn't look scary at all
but he's terrifying
Oh God
uh-huh oh so much worse than San Slendy
that's so much worse that's a million
times worse
ah it's all bad I don't know what it is
about it but it's so scary
it's just so wrong it's so wrong how did
I get back here how did I get back here
ah crap I went in a circle I've only got
four present those alright oh god don't
kill me hahahaha don't show call oh my
ass haha oh that's more one got it Ok Go
Go Go gasps ah going going going oh I'm
going in a circle again ah been this way
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh wow lose
those elf beds oh I can't sprint anymore
I'm out of sprint I'm not afraid are
they gonna give me ha ha get away get
away get away
ahh ahh it's all one
alright saw one I thought I saw one
maybe I didn't saw one I love my flight
I didn't see you think it took my
flashlight away Oh God
that is horrifying
those worse than any Slendy game I've
ever played in my life that was so dead
horrible horrible Oh God
I don't know why it didn't even look
like [ __ ] use just it look just like
jolly Santa but Oh God it was so wrong
it was so wrong and so disturbing all my
childhood memories get torn up let's go
again cuz I'm a fool to myself okay I
know that there be presents this y'all
over yonder this way maybe I shouldn't
sprint so much from then okay thought I
saw something nope okay no no oh man I
tell you I don't know why that was so
bad but man oh man oh it was the best
knows the worst but that was the best a
lovin holy crap dun dun dun dun dun da
da da I mean I just I turned around and
saw his jolly nose and he looked all
happy and nothing bad could possibly
happen to me but Santa did not have any
time for my BS steel in his presence how
do I keep living back are there multiple
snowmen
got to be ah okay so that's two real
quick okay so far so good
Santi Santi Santi snot around slend anta
Slendy Claus I think it's just Santa I
don't think is anything to do with
Slendy
that's just pure plain simple Santa I
wonder if I am an elf and I am revolting
against Santa and trying to steal
presents to start my own Christmas
that's aa static but no Santa was that
oh ho ho ho ho ho ho
where am I going I thought how do I keep
looping in circles like this I swear
I've been that way but I'd go hi I see
you I see you over there Santa I see you
I see you you can't you can't hide from
me I'm gonna get you next time
or maybe not or maybe you're gonna get
me and kill me and murder me and I don't
know I don't know I have a feeling I'm
not gonna beat this game because I feel
like I've been walking in circles
hey wait a minute was in the same fuzz
before maybe they're all in the same
spot maybe there's hope for me yet I see
you over there
I see you over there got a focus on you
to get you in a temporal lock with my
eyeballs these are these are elf beds
they're present in these elf it's hard
to see this light is not very intense oh
don't slow down on me music okay music
do not slow down on me just yet
seriously I need I need to stay sane
please I'll speed up yes thank you where
is he where's he where's all your duck
game a dot five gimme gimme
gimme-gimme-gimme gonna get a gotta cut
up I it's gonna get me on back in the is
you stay over there
I got you locked locked in [ __ ] yeah
that's right
I called you a [ __ ] what you gonna do
about it Santa
murder my eyeballs out okay I see you
there keeping a respectable distance for
having five probably because there is
some sort of time thing where am I going
I keep walking in freaking toggles he's
there he's there oh he's there oh he's
right on my ass oh he's there oh he's
there oh he's right there
oh god it's so bad I don't know I've
been going in circles I didn't plan a
route and I just kind of randomly went a
single direction and oh god I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I better that I'm dead I'm
dead go I said I'm dead I'm dead
go hit sandy Santi Santi Joey [ __ ] I'm
dead so dead I'm told ya I'm so Jeff I
can't read no salad oh god okay you say
you say you say I don't know where am I
on tonight my god okay huh okay
seriously he looks just like jolly old
Saint Nick ah Christmas Oh
Oh God ah it's so wrong it's so wrong
it's so wrong I can't do I can't do any
more it's a wrong it was the greatest
thing ever oh man my opinion out there
and slide your carpet look slender
carnival oh it was good so I'm a cutter
here is silliness so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more views that I've done link is in
the description below and as always
hey hey camera go focus on me and as
always I will see you in the next video
Oh
hey and you do not know